A five
year old emerges
from underneath the rubble in Tu
hard hit Haiti.
One of the
youngest of thousands of lives s
But for too many, it was too lat
In the town of Kirkland,
they mourned one of the many
who've not made it out alive.
With the death toll rising by th
This is a race against time.
How many are buried
under the wreckage of this
massive quake zone?
No one really knows.
Estimates in the tens of thousan
here in under search and rescue
crews work tirelessly around the
digging through
what used to be a 14 storey
residential building
where families lay asleep
when the monstrous earthquake hi
New York
Survivors have gathered
at the site of the rescue missio
There's shelter and hot meals.
And in the bitter cold,
they huddle around these fires.
Everyone with a story of the hor
they've survived.
The shock, the
trauma, the pain visible on ever
Parents doing what they can to t
and make their little ones forge
Many here are anxiously awaiting
of their loved ones and friends
buried under what's left of thei
put down.
They're asking us to get down.
And we believe this is
because they're scanning
the building wreckage.
This is a very,
very careful and delicate operat
That's going on to try and see
if they can locate any survivors
because so far
they haven't been able to
hold no survivors yet
on their lifeless bodies.
Pulled over.
It's been three days.
Why can't they get my son out?
This father wails
as night falls,
the rest of the family wait
desperately for any news of 25 y
old Sirte.
They've been out here for three
long nights.
It's sort of some of it, because
all these nights
we are killing my family, my
things,
the
my cousins, his my cousins, that
he's crying so much.
He's crying so much.
He he's the one that hurts his s
Your cousins died.
We saw him earlier.
He was. He was crying.
He was crying.
You know, it's great.
Good
that this late.
I don't know what to say.
All these we should we should pr
and that is all day and countles
others can do right now.
Jomana Karadsheh, CNN, Adana, Tu